Disney holding your nostalgia to ransom
for 90 years so this is the sort of
thing I don't normally talk about I'm
not entirely sure why I feel like
talking about it this time but I don't
know I'm just gonna ramble it out so
some more details about Disney's plans
to create its own streaming service and
how that is impacting its relationship
with Netflix about a month ago maybe a
little less we already got the initial
announcement that they were planning to
do this and we're going to be taking all
of the Disney branded movies TV shows
etc off of Netflix once that deal
expires
I believe in 2019 what wasn't clear at
that point is what was gonna happen two
other properties owned by Disney but not
necessarily brand it as such namely Star
Wars and Marvel now the word was at the
time that active negotiations were going
on with Netflix so that possibly the
service was gonna keep them well we
found out that's not gonna be the case
Star Wars and Marvel are going to be
yanked off of Netflix along with
everything else and moved over to
Disney's I believe as yet unnamed
streaming service so my immediate
question which I have not been able at
least at the time of this recording to
get a 100% answer on is how this is
going to impact the current and future
state of the Netflix Marvel superhero
shows because those aren't wholly owned
by Disney Netflix actually co-produces
them so those can't just be yanked away
once the deal expires the way other
stuff can so there's a couple of
possibilities to this one is that over
the next two years they simply wrap up
the story and then that's that and then
it's just a question of coming up with a
licensing agreement for Disney to get it
back whether you know they pay Netflix
to basically wholly own them or
something along those lines and then
they'll leave with everything else if
Disney doesn't feel like footing that
kind of bill which I they could
certainly afford but maybe they don't
want to they could continue to develop
those properties on Netflix for as
as it is profitable for both companies
to do so but at least until we get a
specific announcement about something
changing there those shows won't be
leaving Netflix coz as I said Disney
doesn't own them wholly but everything
else is gonna go and my general feeling
about that well it's funny my feelings
change slightly depending on the company
doing it so for instance CBS is putting
out its own streaming service and I hate
that largely because they are holding
the new Star Trek Discovery Series to
ransom behind a paywall that show though
buddy's going to have its premiere on
CBS proper is going to have subsequent
episodes exclusive to the service which
is BS because CBS does not have a back
catalog of stuff that justifies signing
up for a service just for their stuff
and basically holding a new series to
ransom is utter crap and I can't say
that Disney's gonna do that directly I
mean we don't really know but I think
it's a fairly good shot to say that they
will be making some things that will
premiere and probably be exclusive to
their streaming service at least
initially you know maybe something that
they make for the streaming service will
later air on Disney XD or ABC or
whatever but then they probably will in
an attempt to do value added stuff and
make the service more profitable have
stuff that is made exclusively for it
although I doubt it will be major ticket
stuff that is gonna be held to ransom
the way the Star Trek property is being
done by CB is by CBS as I said my
opinion changes slightly because of who
it is I'm less ticked off at Disney
because as much as I don't like this
move as a practice because it's an anti
consumer move there's no benefit to the
consumer for this to happen to have to
go and sign up for different streaming
services for each different owner of
stuff that they like that is not
particularly convenient that being said
the current model where stuff is on
Netflix or Hulu or Amazon Prime
whatever for a couple of years and then
potentially move somewhere else that's
not particularly consumer friendly
either so I'm not idle I I'm not
idealizing the system that we have right
now but the more services that get
creative the more annoying it becomes
further the consumers and I am an
outsider looking in I'm not part of the
industry I am a consumer so on premise
I'm not a huge fan of this that having
been said if there's one company whose
backlog of material plus the rate and
the volume of new material they're
creating could actually justify paying a
subscription service to get access to
all of it at a moment's notice through
streaming honestly it's Disney because
they have got going on 90 years worth of
stuff that they've already produced
movies shorts television live-action
realize that ESPN is owned by Disney so
that's a factor in this they own ABC
they own Marvel they own Star Wars
there's all the shows that they Eve
there have made in the past work or are
going to make the future for things like
Disney XD ABC all this stuff so this is
a massive amount of content and there
aren't all that many potential companies
who could do something like this who
would ever have the volume of content
that Disney has that that could rival
that that kind of lineup depending on
what the price point is it might
actually be worth it in terms of how
much stuff you're actually gonna get
access to does that mean I'm actually
gonna sign up for it probably not I
don't need another bill in my life aside
from sort of mic reflex on just the idea
of more of these services being created
and having to sign up for more more
things just to get what I want for what
they have control of they can kind of
justify it I mean not justified in any
sense to that it's a benefit to the
consumer I mean they're doing this to
consolidate everything get money
directly as opposed to only get money
from licensing and then Netflix rakes it
in so obviously this is a completely
self-serving move but they can
what they can offer you for the price is
potentially a lot of stuff what I'm much
more afraid of is less Disney doing this
themselves rather than all the bandwagon
jumpers oh well and I say bandwagon
jumpers Disney's not the first to really
try and do this as I mentioned CBS
already has a streaming and and you know
most of the premium cable channels have
streaming like HBO Showtime whatever but
they don't they don't make it shows
exclusive to the streaming service but
it's a factor so you know these
companies having streaming just for the
stuff that's not new but if Disney
doesn't other companies are gonna follow
suit now if we are lucky they will wait
and see how well this works for Disney
before they make any decisions
unfortunately what I think is more
likely is the major competitors to
Disney are going to see what they're
doing and then try and get the ball
rolling before they even know if this
works which means we're gonna see all
this content know gutted out of services
like Netflix like Hulu like Amazon Prime
leaving them as shells of what they once
were
and as all these these different
companies start up their own thing I
mean Warner Brothers Time Warner they
could easily do it Viacom could do it
and probably will if they haven't
already decided to do so now whether
these things will work I mean from from
a business standpoint maybe it's it's
hard to say here's one thing that I wish
they would realize this is this is
really going to cause a spike in piracy
cuz it's been I'm not the first to point
this out but the best way you can combat
piracy is to make the legal way to
acquire something easier than the
illegal way so like the way that music
piracy basically kind of went under
aside from young taking Napster to court
and all that other stuff was ultimately
iTunes itunes and Apple made it super
easy just to click a button and get the
thing
wanted and that model and things like it
have shown and you know things like
Steam on for PC gaming and all that kind
of stuff has shown that if you make it
convenient and you're not gong on the
price it's reasonably priced people are
willing to pay for this stuff
if pirating is harder however when you
keep subdividing content across all
these multiple platforms so the only way
to get it to get what you want legally
used to sign up for like five different
services no there's gonna be a spike in
piracy because it's not going to be
notably less convenient to just go to
torrents and do all this other stuff I'm
not advocating piracy I actually I I
take a bit of a stance against it as a
as a content creator and someone who
wishes they could make a living doing
this sort of stuff I am I'm really kind
of not okay with piracy accepting the
situations where you actually literally
can't get something legally I mean there
are cases where content hasn't been
released in the US and things like that
I'm like you know what it's something
you love it's the only way you can get
it fine but in terms of if you have the
option to by opting to pirate it I'm not
in favor of that but realistically this
this is gonna spike I mean this for
God's sakes this is what Nintendo is
seeing with you know it saw with the NES
classic and now the SNES classic where
they did this really limited number of
things and people want them massive
amounts of people want them but because
it's such a pain in the butt to get them
tons of people are just making our just
stocking up on little emulator devices
that aren't the real thing and are
questionable legality but they're gonna
do it cuz you made it too much of a pain
in the butt to get the legitimate the
real thing and Wow you know Disney
making its own Street View services and
on things like that is not exactly a
one-to-one parallel with what Nintendo
has done with with these sorts of things
I I think the the core of what I'm
saying holds true the mooring
convenient you make it to get things a
legitimate way the more piracy is going
to thrive so I don't know if they've
taken that into account I think what
we're probably gonna say I think we're
gonna see the start of another cycle cuz
I think in a lot of ways what happened o
couple of decades or so so you just sort
of going back television originally was
just network television you had the
major networks and you had like your
local channel they get picked up on
rabbit ears so that was pretty much it
then cable came along and cable gave the
opportunity for things to get more
specialized and so you had channels
really focused on single genres single
you know mentalities or in the case of
something like the Disney Channel or
Nickelodeon single demographics a single
brand worth of stuff
and and that was okay but then there
kept getting more and more and more and
it kept subdividing and it just it kind
of got out of control with how many
cable channels they there were and the
way you had to buy these bundles you
couldn't just get the ones you wanted
and then something like Netflix came
along and once Netflix moved on past its
just doing his discs and got into
streaming it really changed the whole
game because it suddenly like wait I can
just pay this one service and get all
this stuff like maybe it's not
absolutely everything I wish I was
watching but this is a lot of stuff this
is more than enough and you've seen a
lot of people do you know cut the cord
it's bid became kind of a rallying cry
for a bit there so you had this thing
where you know first we had a wealth of
options but the options became
inconvenient I'm talking about cable
with that and then he got consolidated
into something like Netflix and Hulu and
then so there were a couple of services
but there weren't too many now we're
seeing the subdividing again because
people are getting greedy and I think
what will probably happen is Disney will
do this and it'll probably do okay and
then other
companies will do it I'll subdivide and
then they'll either be start to become
either less profitable because you know
people are just kind of paid cuz here's
the advantage of this over the old cable
model because cable as I said used to
bundle channels together so okay well
you you can get you know this one
channel you really want but you're gonna
have to pay us 40 bucks and it comes
with these thirty other channels that
you don't give a darn about so having
these streaming services for you know
these companies does at least eliminate
the bundling problem so it will empower
people to get just the stuff that they
want I mean the thing is though people
aren't as brand loyal as these companies
hope no one's going to get Disney and go
well I am all set for my entertainment
needs forever I need nothing else cuz
look I love Disney especially if I'm
taking into account Marvel and Star Wars
and everything else they put out a lot
of stuff that I love I need more than
that in my life so you know people are
gonna pick and choose and with the
ability to pick and choose whoever has
the least number of really valuable
enticing options they're gonna slant
downhill and then eventually whichever
ones aren't doing as well as they want
they're gonna go crawling back to
Netflix or Hulu or whoever's left and
depending on how those companies fare as
this stuff gets ripped away and things
are gonna get reconsolidated again and
then that will be actually more consumer
friendly and I think it's just gonna
keep cycling because what what is
happening is the consumer friendly
option becomes available and happens and
consumers flock to it and then
corporations think okay but how can we
make this more profitable and they
kneecap the consumer friendly option and
then we're stuck with whatever that is
until a newer consumer friendly option
comes around we'd all flock to that
again so it's it's just annoying at this
point and as I said I'm not I'm not as
annoyed with Disney I'm kind of just
Disney but it but it's the idea that
that I think this is really gonna cause
a snowball effect with all the sort of
stuff so yeah I don't have a bigger
overall conclusion to all this like I
said this isn't even the sort of stuff I
normally talk about and I might never
bring it up again maybe you don't care
my thoughts on this but if you got here
to the end what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcasts also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]